وفي العاصمه الايسلنديه ريكيا تتواصل
لليوم الثاني اعمال قمه مجلس اوروبا
لمناقشه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا لمشاركه
قاده اكثر من اربعين دوله اوروبيه وشهد
اليوم الاول للاجتماع دعوات من القاده
المشاركين للمضي قدما فيما سموه تقديم
روسيا للعداله من خلال انشاء محكمه خاصه
لهذا الغرض وسجل لتجميع الادله الخاصه
بهذا الامر وقال الرئيس الاوكراني الذي
يشارك عن بعد بان بلاده ما زالت تنتظر
مزيدا من الدعم سيشهد اليوم الثاني
والاخير توقيع دول المنظمه على سجل
للاضرار والجرائم التي تحدث في اوكرانيا
تمهيدا لاستخدامها عند انشاء المحكمه
واعلنت قمه مجلس اوروبا عن انشاء سجل لحصر
الاضرار التي لحقت باوكرانيا جراء الحرب
التي شنتها عليها روسيا يعد قرار انشاء
السجل الذي سيكون مقره الرئيسي في لهايه
من اولى الخطوات التي اتخذت لمحاسبه موسكو
على افعالها في اوكرانيا
حول الموضوع انضم الينا من مراسل الجزيره
عبد الله الشامي عبد الله اهلا بك حدثنا
اكثر حول اولا اهميه هذا المجلس هذه
المنظمه واهميه هذه الخطوه والسجل اذا
للاضرار اللاحقه به اوكرانيا
نعم سكان هذه المنظمه انشات بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه للتركيز اكثر ربما من
غيرها او مثيلاتها في الاتحاد الاوروبي
على ملف حقوق الانسان وبالتالي قيام هذه
المنظمه بالتحديد التي تضم في عضويتها كلا
من الاتحاد الاوروبي ودوله وكذلك دول
النيتو بالاضافه الى دول الجوار القريبه
من اوروبا مثل اذربيجانو تركيا وغيرهم هذه
المنظمه يعني من خلال هذا الاعلان اليوم
هي تضع اولى اللبنات لمحاسبه روسيا كما
قال البيان الصادر هذا الصباح وهناك حديث
ايضا عن ان هذا هو هي الخطوه الاولى لا
زالت هناك خطوات كثيره لكن التركيز على
هذا الملف هو لاجل ربما امرائين الاول هو
حصر الاضرار التي يعني تسببت فيها هذه
الحرب سواء فيما يخص المدنيين او كذلك
ايضا في المسؤولين عن هذه الانتهاكات
بالطبع كما ورد في الخبر مقر هذه هذا
السجل لا يمكن ان نقول بعد انه محكمه خاصه
كما طالب التحرير الاوروبي وانما هو اكثر
للتوثيق والحصر فيما يخص هذه الجرائم
سيكون في لاهاي في هولندا التي قال رئيس
وزرائها اليوم ايضا ان بلاده مستعده للعمل
مع اوكرانيا وكذلك مع المحاكم الموجوده
بالفعل في بلاده الجنائيه الدوليه ومحكمه
العدل الدوليه كذلك للعمل على ايصال
المسؤولين كما اسمائهم عن هذه الامور الى
العداله وبالتالي هي خطوه اولى ينتظر في
المرحله المقبله على الاقل خلال هذا الصيف
ان يعني يتم ربما الانتقال الى الخطوات
الاخرى خصوصا ان رئيس الرئيس الروسي كان
قد صدر له قرار اعتقال بالفعل في مارس
الماضي من قبل الجنايه الدوليه بسبب ما
قيل انه ترحيل الاطفال الاوكرانيين
بالقوه الى روسيا وهو الذات النقطه التي
ايضا اعتمد عليها اعتمد عليها المنظمه
اليوم في انشاء هذا السجل
شكرا لكم مراسل الجزيره عبد الله الشامي
كنت معنا من